Well, some exciting news came out today about Larry Ellison Oracle's CEO coming out and saying that there's a new cancer vaccine
coming our way that we can take some blood from a cancer patient within 48 hours. We can have a vaccine that alters their DNA
so that they can fight this cancer.
Huge announcement, $500 billion investment into AI technology, artificial intelligence working at its finest, so they say.
Well, let's discuss this just a little bit.
So this is all coming out of what's called CRISPR technology. It's actually genetic editing.
So it's gene editing CRISPR as an acronym that's talking about gene editing that allows scientists to basically modify our DNA of a living person
so we can go in and modify the DNA now trying to use artificial intelligence to find out where there's issues that can be modified to change our body's reaction to a disease.
The idea that I've been following CRISPR technology, I'm following CRISPR newsletter that has all the latest articles that are coming out about CRISPR technology.
Who's doing all this investigation, the pharmaceutical companies? They're the ones that are pumping all this money into CRISPR technology to change our DNA in the idea that we will no longer have diseases because we can change our DNA.
Well, so CRISPR is going to go in there, what it is doing is you're basically going in and altering a segment of one's DNA that could be a cause of disease.
Sounds really promising and really scary at the same time. On the positive note, you think there's genetic factors in a lot of diseases.
Though one would argue that 99% of cancers are not genetic, they are our response to our environment. So it's environmental toxins that we're exposed to that affects our genes and then damages our genes and then causes cell replication.
But if we could, let's pretend to go in and change oncogenes, remember, oncogenes are those genetic factors that can promote a cancer or we could change defects in tumor suppressor gene families.
So there's different tumor suppressor genes that turn on within the cell that's like God's way of protecting us from cancer.
So when a cancer does occur, let's say we're exposed to poisons, toxins get in our cells and damage the DNA and it starts our cells start to replicate tumor suppressor genes kick in and therefore destroy the cell from inside.
They stimulate a caspase pathway, which is an intrinsic apoptonic destructive pathway. So 99% of the time we have cancer cells and our body is killing it and we never get diagnosed with cancer because the tumor suppressor system kicks in and destroys the cell before it's ever large enough to be diagnosed.
Remember, a cancer has to be at least 3 million cells large to be seen on a CT scan, PET scanner, MRI. So it's gotten, you know, it's taken some time to get that large.
If our tumor suppressor system is working, we never get cancer. The truth is, even those that have a diagnosis of cancer have multiple other primary cancer starting to die all the time.
So your tumor suppressor gene system is never not working. It just may have defects so that it's not working maybe at 100% we could say.
So if we can use CRISPR technology to change those tumor suppressor genes and get them working at 100% so there's no defects in those gene in those specific tumor suppressor genes, it sounds wonderful.
Could it work? I don't know.
To CRISPR technology could affect drug resistance, so chemotherapy drugs don't work on everybody.
So could we change the genetic pathways specifically? In this case, it'd be mainly our detoxification pathways and such so that we are able to detox those chemistries, those poisons when we're using them so it doesn't affect our healthy cells quite so much.
And could to could CRISPR technology affect our T cells and natural killer cells so it could up regulate them to help our body kill cancer.
That's kind of what immunotherapy is tempting to do currently. So it has all these promising things and that's really what they're selling it as, that's how they're getting funding because they have all these promising ideas and they're coming out with articles and look at what we can do.
So, question is, is this a good thing or it is a bad thing? I don't know. We don't know that yet. There's a lot of negative press about CRISPR technology that you don't really hear about,
in fact you might have heard of CRISPR technology to this point, but there's a lot of negative press.
You know, well meaning very intelligent people that are saying, you know, when we're starting to play with DNA to treat cancer, we actually might be promoting malignancies.
The other doctor and the same articles talking about that we that changing our DNA can actually affect cancer and make cancer grow more.
So we just don't know how the bodies going to respond to changing DNA.
There was a recent interview with HBO's John Oliver and he actually had a really interesting quote by a late person.
It seems like Gene Editing is going to eliminate all disease, he said, or it's just going to kill every last one of us.
A lot of truth in that statement. We just don't know. One of the things we do know with everything, it's smart to do your investigation.
And one at least piece of that investigation has to be to follow the money.
Oh my word, if you do some little bit of research into how many drug companies owned by a lot of the big conglomerate drug companies are all pushing creating vaccines.
There's thousand more vaccines on the market that they're trying to push because they're so much money in vaccines and they're protected by so many governmental agencies against lawsuits.
It's all just clear money. Follow the money didn't take long to pull up some data on how many companies are creating this.
Well, even in today's announcement by Larry Ellison, boy, he came out and had all these grand claims that we can diagnose cancer using AI.
Well, that's kind of a strong word on this artificial intelligence that's never wrong.
It's funny if you just search some things about AI, how wrong it can be even to try to populate a picture on the internet.
But through AI, through a simple blood test, he says, once we sequence the genes of that cancer tumor, we can design an mRNA vaccine for each individual romantically using AI in about 48 hours.
Boy, does that sound promising.
However, there's multiple different articles that say personalized cancer vaccine design using AI power technologies has all sorts of problems that can take place.
Many of the problems that we have no idea what the problem could be.
So I'm really happy about this new idea of using AI to better our genes and to help propagate a cure for people with cancer.
But I'm also very skeptical.
Interesting this Larry Ellison also was the same Larry Ellison who said just a few months ago that AI field surveillance systems can ensure citizens will be on their best behavior.
That kind of makes me scratch my head.
What is he really trying to do?
I just have a sneaky suspicion that people behind some of this aren't really for our betterment.
I don't know, I could be wrong.
But certainly Moderna stocks surged after Larry Ellison called out the potentials of AI and cancer vaccines.
And there's billions of dollars going into funding all this stuff.
It's amazing how much money is flowing through hands.
It's kind of crazy.
If you look at this, there's an article that just came out.
It really states that this cancer vaccine, quote unquote, is really not a cancer vaccine.
And that's okay. But it's really a form of immunotherapy was what they're trying to do.
And that's okay. We've used immunotherapy with cancer for years, some successes, some not so good successes.
But to promise that it's going to destroy cancer with people in 48 hours might be going on a little bit on a stretch.
Maybe it was just to get the $500 billion in funding.
I don't know. Call me a skeptic.
There's a lot of alternative people that are coming against it.
And you're going to see more and more alternative people that are going to bring up possible dangers of it.
I'm a little skeptic because it's really funded by and produced by the same people that came out with the last vaccine, quote unquote.
It's an MRNA vaccine that has destroyed countless number of lives, even though they're still trying to deny it.
Even though there's data like pouring through the floorboards of dangers of that last vaccine that we dealt with.
So is this a good thing or a bad thing? I don't know.
I just hope for the best if it can cure some people and set people into a state of remission.
I am all for it.
But I have my sneaky suspicion and my spidey senses are up there.
Again, all we can do is be in deep prayer about it for our life.
Pray for the good for other people and pray for protection and pray for discernment.
That's my take on the new cancer vaccine.